[Music]
so here's a fun way to start off this is
something I did recently I got in touch
with my feminine side so weird way to
start it sounds like something to do
with a shower head not on the card what
I mean by getting in touch with my
feminine side is I'm multi-dimensional
I'm more than just a pretty face and a
set of curiously wide hips
oh no I've got a whole nother side to me
and it's feminine and I touched it with
a shower it no I let me explain I
recently had a girls night out me I had
a girls night out I don't mean I hung
out with a bunch of girls for a night
that's not what I mean what I mean is me
and my friend Oren who's right there
who's also a man we had a girls night
out together just us fellas and it was
fabulous I know you're thinking that
doesn't make any sense that's not that's
a guys night out that's not a girls
night no it isn't a guys night out is
when you're doing guy looking for
sex and high-fiving before and after
said sex occurs sometimes during can't
believe that is on the card
that's a guys night out girls can have
that too sometimes a group of ladies
will comb the town together
just like that's a guys night out a
girls night out isn't about any of that
stuff and it's certainly not about sex
it's not about drinking it's about being
with your friends never separating from
the group and of course you dance and
that's what we did there was dancing we
found ourselves in a honky-tonk in
Austin Texas and grew yes and girls
listen to this approached us and asked
us to two-step that's right they hit on
us probably scoping us out the second we
walked in bird dogging us like dibs on
the doughy one
he said no the acid to dance we said no
at first then they bought us drinks
they bought us drinks lots and lots of
drinks I'm talking beers and shots
those girls were trying to get these
girls drunk I was so flattered I was
like ladies ladies a few more at least I
might just make a mistake next thing I
know I'm out on the dance floor
you're not gonna believe this I'm not
making a stitch of this story up she was
leading I swear to God she was leading
she was like five three and she was
hopping to twirl me I swear she spun me
like a little girl putting the angel on
top of the Christmas tree like that on a
dance floor and we were drunk so it's
really dissimilar in a lot of ways to
then she started dancing dirty dirty
dancing her idea I've heard stories of
guys and clubs rubbing their southern
bulges on girls give them a preview but
this girl kept accidentally rubbing her
boobs on me those are her northern
bulges
next thing I know I swear another girl
comes out of nowhere and taps that girl
on the shoulder listen to this true
story taps are on the shoulder and asks
if she can have this dance I was like a
princess in a fairy tale different
ladies were coming up asking the other
lady to cut in what episode of Twilight
Zone is this and somewhere amidst all
this booty shaking and dancing I got it
you know dancing it's like the chemistry
test it's essentially a way of asking
what do you think of my body close to
your body don't answer now
just could you see yourself doing this
later naked and less rhythmically so I'm
picking that up I'm having a hell of a
time to steppin but then I realized
something
I lost Oran yeah I broke the cardinal
rule of a girls night out the group had
been separated and just then the woman I
was dancing with was like hey maybe what
do you say we get out of here and grab
some food or something
nice try that means I just looked right
at her
[Music]